có nghĩa cụ chè không biết biết, mà nghĩa tên người ta không ra gặp mặt,
người ta không nãy sĩnh, cũng sẽ nghĩ sĩnh là khổ.
Và biết biết, mà những cái quen quen quen quen quen, là đại cụ có mình ra,
đúng không?
Ởa chật, khi quen nha nãy cứu có những cái quen quen, là nặp bà như bà như bà như bà như đúng.
Và ở chỉ vì cái chạp biết quen quen.
Và đây nặng nãy là nặp bố như bà như bà như thế.
Bật, các bạn của chúng ta tiền bố để là họ bố lòng người ra, chúng ta đúng không?
Không có tâm tìm vì khách bọn lượng lượng lượng lượng lượng lượng lượng lượng lượng lượng lượng châu bản rất nọ.
Tì họ bị theo viên hạ.
Chính vì có người thì tiền bố bị thích.
Các bạn chỉ trường biết thì có không chào mạng ra.
Các bạn rất nhiều, không chào chức hạng dữ rân.
Để chúng ta đi rất cảnh cái đấy là
Thì chuyển không
Quỏ cao
Thì chuyển lại cho các thế
Và tôi tiên rằng cả em
Thì thôi
Mặc dù là em chưa làm việc là có thể là
Chứ cái em
Lúc luôn được cả tỉ thử ra không?
Không làm việc là không?
Không được không?
Không phải làm
Hứa bây giờ
Cái điều tiết của
Nhưng thế, ý chức
Nặp vào thế, cho không này là có cơ sợ